ah
awesome looks so good
trap oh my god this is the traps
carol danver it's just okay got it
that's oh this is
scarlet witch baby
i i did i
she's getting her children back she said
not today
not today oh my gosh i think i stole it
welcome back to new rock stars one
division just
broke a lot of hearts but you know in
good ways and in bad
hopefully uh you know leaving us
well with no mephisto no mutants no
multiverse
yet but we do got some scrolls we got a
dark old and we got some big old nuts to
dr strange
jess we ask this every week but this
time we really need it
wanda the
this is inside marvel it's our one
division after show i'm eric boss i'm
here with jess clements
uh let me have it jess
[Laughter]
hmm
i'm so sad i'm sad to you
it's sad it's also so obvious like i'm
sad that it's ending
and i'm sad because it was like it was
an easy like
every friday like it was just like my
schedule was down to a t
and every episode astounded me and i
just wanted to keep going forever and
maybe i was in my own hecks
i think we are all a bit in our own hex
a hex of our own making uh reality of
our own choosing
uh look a lot of our theories were
debunked uh
or at least punted you know doesn't mean
memphis does dead forever
you go watch others the kind of bat [ __ ]
theory video we dropped in the dead of
night
uh for me revealing that i am uh still
kind of on the mepista train just
obviously not for one division he was
not in this show that train is going to
crash and it already has oh it has it'll
you're gonna be yeah jessica the train
has derailed it is crashed it's now just
plowing through streets like at the end
of speed
but now it's people are just looking at
it like i guess it's just another
vehicle on the freeway that i gotta
dodge
inception you are the train just coming
through in the middle of the town
and everyone's like what do we do and
it's like i don't know just let it go i
guess
right this is a train that has no um uh
friction at all
it's just like constant inertia no
forces of nature
can bring this to a halt i still respect
that you you literally we made the joke
before make it again
you are the titanic you are not the ship
but the people playing the instruments
on the ship you are the
i'm the captain of the titanic the
titanic yeah you literally go lay in
your bed or look at those pictures you
go down with the ship
unlike me where i was like i truly am
billy zane i'm jumping ship i'm stealing
a child
and i'm running away because i know i'm
wrong i don't want to be too wrong
theories aside a very very uh
emotional final episode of wanda vision
uh some really really beautiful moments
in there
uh it's there's so much to this show
ultimately it was what we thought it was
a show about wanda and her grief
and her attempt to let go of vision and
how hard that is and let go of her
dreams
and uh on that measure the show
delivered
it it did stick that landing now there
were some issues with
like letting the fan theories run away
with it and you could blame the fans for
that
absolutely come at me blame me but there
is the art of expectation management and
there are certain things
like not just saying that fietro
is not fox x-men quicksilver but going
as far to name him
boner felt like a bit of a slap in the
face to some
i would imagine i left that train a
while ago but
imagine if like not only was mephisto
not in this but just like
you know one of those kids just pees on
some sidewalk chart that uh chalk that
looks like the devil
that's what the equivalent of it would
be like we don't need that too
this episode was it was wild let's get
it let's start but
we got to get into it so
yeah the season finale delivered this
witch duel between wanda and agatha
and wanda trapping agatha ultimately
with what we can surmise was roon
law i love it uh and then we had the
battle divisions with vision beating
white vision with a wooden ship paradox
the ship of theseus i love it with sound
uh uh plato logic plutarch logic lots of
them i talked about it and then as we
said pietro is a random dude an aspiring
actor named ralph boner
okay uh hey jessica scroll's on the
loose
scrolls on the loose look
and then we end with the second
post-credits team we got two of them
this week uh
wanda is a bruce banner-esque uh
unibomber figure living in the mountains
doing some doctor strange-esque astral
projection
to study up on the dark hole the scarlet
witch now if you're watching this you
may have some mixed feelings about the
finale you may be feeling confused don't
worry we all feel this way that's what
jessica and i
are here for we're gonna help you
through this we're gonna
do our best to explain what these uh
both of these post-credit scenes mean
how this story will go on and dr
strange's multiverse of madness and
interesting question where did white
vision go i can't wait
can't wait to discuss it and i know a
lot of you have been rubbing your palms
to see
this nerd nerd nerd uh see his heart
broken
i we're gonna talk about mephisto at the
end of this episode don't worry and
tomorrow will be my in-depth shot by
shot breakdown of all the easter eggs in
this episode
and uh a lot of you've been asking
jessica and i will be doing one more
inside marvel one division
uh season wrap up coming wednesday of
next week we're gonna look into all the
unanswered questions of the series
because there are a lot
and uh jessica it has been so amazing
talking to you about
wanda vision uh you're gonna see a lot
more of jessica on new rockstars don't
worry
i'm not dead i'm not gonna disappear for
23 years like i said i was
mike maybe it depends on how fun i am
you know summer almost
it's almost summer uh and
you're gonna see jessica on this next
week week's upcoming big question
episode
um yeah she's gonna be a very regular
familiar face on the channel
i'm so excited to be collaborating with
you even more jessica because
inside marvel has been such a blast i am
here to talk nerd stuff
and to talk nerd stuff with you all the
time anytime especially if it involves
vision or wanda because they're my
favorites
they're my favorites and speaking of uh
vision at least i am wearing our latest
obsession shirt an unusual couple it's
got its secret augmented reality easter
eggs we still have some of these left
but they are
selling out fast yeah and these are uh a
custom
limited run so they're gonna go back in
the blue dungeon and we're gonna have a
new latest obsession so you gotta get on
it fast
and when you do this you get the
opportunity to write in a custom shout
out that appears at the bottom of these
inside marvel episodes
uh here are some that are gonna see at
the bottom let's see william yeager asks
who do you think
is the next big bad of the mcu uh i
would say wanda based off of this
uh episode of one division honestly i
think it's gonna be kang the conqueror
right i think kang the conqueror is at
least
the multi-title villain for now we might
get dr doom and galactus on the other
side of him but in terms of a villain
who spans like
both loki and quantomania i think might
be king
let's see dominique simpson uh says i
think wanda will cause a rip in time and
the events of falcon winter soldier
will be them stopping criminals from i
using i guess from from using that maybe
ooh i don't know if falcon winter
soldier is going to go that far into the
multiverse
what about you jess we talked about this
slightly
on our rogue theory that came out
yesterday and i don't think so either
because of
the the behind the scenes stuff of like
it's supposed to be coming out
before it i think maybe a little bit but
i don't think it's gonna affect too much
i do think it's just gonna be like a
buddy cop kind of situation
yeah i mean they're gonna have to answer
the question of where the hell old cap
came exactly
must have come from the multiverse
somewhere right and then uh lucia nazaro
says you better watch out jannika
um i don't know what that means but we
wanted to shout it out
because jannika someone's coming for you
you better watch i don't know what
happened between you two but look out
behind you oh and we also want to shout
out our friend from real rejects greg
alba he wrote hexagons when he got his
shirt uh
several weeks ago buddy we want to thank
you for supporting us
go easy on me and your reaction to my
easter egg breakdown
theorizing smarts oh and yes uh we are
simulcasting this live on stereo get the
app for free and follow us at stereo dot
com
new rockstars if you're listening to us
on stereo right now stick around for a
bonus segment at the end of the show in
which we will react in real time to the
voicemails
that you send us all right jessica let's
dive into it
wanda the [ __ ] was the second post
credit scene how will one division
continue and resolve doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness yes yes so
i started to talk about this in the
video that we released last night uh
this second post-credits scene
visits wanda in her um sort of
retirement or
uh reclusion in some mountain cabin
uh we don't know where this is i said it
was might have been sokovia
uh jessica do you think this might have
been uh the
wounded gore mountain maybe that'd be
sick i don't think it is uh
i don't think it is oh me and my oh god
i'm so mad we talked about it last night
i didn't write notes for this episode i
was like i'm gonna go full on rogue i'm
just gonna like remember everything up
here
and that's my fault i do think she's
just in some random part of mountains
maybe as far as way as possible
if it is sakovia that would make sense
because it's like no one's gonna look
for wanda in sokovia
though she's from there it's like that's
the last place she should be
so yeah she's trying to go as remote as
possible where no one
like if sword is looking for her they're
not gonna look in sokovia they're gonna
be like why would she go back there
oh i i could imagine them looking for
her there but maybe she creates some
kind of like
you know in uh deathly hallows part one
where they go glamping and they're
they're able to create those uh hexes so
that
people can't see them maybe she might be
doing a version of that where she's like
i'm invisible at first i thought she was
you know she was doing like the dr
manhattan watchman thing where like
he was sleeping with his partner but
also fixing stuff i was like oh yeah and
then i was like what if she's using that
as a front so if people pass by the
cabin they don't go check inside they
see a woman is sitting outside
but she's actually inside doing all this
crazy dark magic stuff
that woman's just sipping her morning
tea we don't need to bother her
so relaxed and calm with her folgers and
then it behind you just
she's just like listening to her dead
children speak
oh and and uh in terms of a location a
lot of people are saying this might be
like bruce banner's uh mountain cabin at
the end of the ed norton incredible hulk
uh i checked out the the geography the
background it's a different area
uh that looks like it was in canada in
the canadian wilderness i think that's
where they said that was
i don't think that's where she is now
those mountains looked far
rockier and uh and not like the
mountains that were behind
bruce banner's cabin but yeah she's
reading the dark hold
and what's interesting here is there's a
lot of doctor strange parallels jessica
uh
the music is a doctor strange theme and
it looks like she's astral projecting
reading the dark hold and that's how
there are two separate versions of her
and the way that dr strange while he was
sleeping was able to astral project and
kind of multitask
and study up his soul his mind while he
was resting that's kind of what wanda's
doing here i think it's
indicating that she's like kind of you
know uh
training like rocky and rocky iv doing
it her way
bracing for a battle with the sorcerer
supreme whom
we found out this episode was name
dropped and
his powers are not as strong as the
scarlet witch
according to agatha in the darkhold this
is the only and
i'm gonna say it clear here i'm not
disappointed
in the show at all because the last
episode i'm not disappointed in the last
episode at all i think they
did a great job writing it and then like
to
be like it's bad because my theories
weren't proven it doesn't give a
justification
but this was the one thing i was really
disappointed about was they clear in the
sand
drew a line that said magic doctor
strange
and then we didn't get any like real big
big ties to dr strange's next movie
and i was like um come on you guys
already like spelled it out you
literally spelled out doctor strange i
want to see
some sort of like connection right now
like physical connection i don't want to
see it in his movie i want to see it
now but so did you want uh benedict
cumberbatch cameo
or a shot of the sanctum sanctorum or
what would have been
like even wong like i just i won yeah
okay so
i know that there's probably so many
things that we've already talked about
with doctor strange too
but just like even if they're like
fighting something that's bigger than
wanda because wanna just took over west
view they're probably not that
preoccupied with what she's
doing they're probably like we're
fighting like a god
in the space again she's just taking
over new jersey you guys can handle it
it's wanda maxum off
um i'm still like you could have sent
someone else out there
to like go talk to her to be like yeah
oh you do have all this magic
and so and so now they're just gonna
have a battle scene where i'm like
doctor strange you're gonna lose if you
go against her one-on-one she's like
fueled with emotions right now she's
trying to retrieve it and fueled with it
seems like
all the past switches it seems like
she's absorbing agatha
and that whole coven so it's like gonna
be like what
a dozen against one with uh dr strange
that's true real talk
she's straight up gonna that's why i
think she's gonna be the villain she's
just fueled with just like
i need to get my children back and i
think this is also opening the door to
the real house of m
stuff where she's gonna open different
dimensions to go find those situations
and that's where it's like now we're
hitting it boom
i was mistaken i thought this was all
house of m but it's just
now it's starting yeah i had a feeling i
agree jessica i had i had a feeling that
this uh whole show was just gonna be
setting up a bigger
broader house of m style event and
multiverse of madness oh then you're
right there you go
but i i had hoped that you know and i
had theorized that
in the final episode we would see the
beginning of that moment
of like reality blowing up kind of like
the way episode six ended i was like
okay that's setting up an even further
expansion yeah
like expanding into a prism yeah these
different hexes same way
not exactly i was like oh after agatha's
whole room was
shown i was like oh we're gonna get into
everything and then we kind of
didn't just emotionally it was
and i think that's what and that's what
we should give them credit for they gave
us a little bit of like
a cat of pay and i went that's good i
want more and they're like you gotta
wait
yeah and i think that's what's uh tough
is like uh and a lot of people countered
my mephisto theorizing with this
like if you drop in things like the
multiverse too soon or merciful
mephisto too soon we were general casual
viewers are gonna be like whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa what what what what
uh what is this and they're gonna be
thrown
so ultimately you just got to stay true
to the story that you're telling which
in this case was the story of wanda in
her grief
and her mental health that's true that's
a real that's a real thing that's what i
need to hold on to which i will grasp
going forward at the rest of this
episode that is real talk yes
but as we're looking ahead i mean it
right now it just looks like juan is
doing her training she's doing her
homework before she beca
can become this house of m figure and
what you just said earlier jessica i
think is right on the money it's gonna
be about her kids
and that's what kind of tells us this is
gonna be a house of m style event uh
and those voices from the dark hold
where those
boys screaming for help it kind of
sounds like wanda is gonna be going
universe by universe trying to find
these kids these lost kids
and uh and that's what's gonna cause
some of the chaos and the madness
of uh a multiverse of madness uh because
by
visiting all these different universes
she's gonna like knock loose other stuff
that should not
yeah do you think she's just gonna
kidnap
billy and tommy from a different
dimension from a different wanda yes
yeah exactly so like what is she is she
gonna rick and morty and find the
like reality where they're dead or where
the like where she's dead and then just
like become the mom of those two
wanda potion number nine yeah yeah
they're looking for her
yeah so she's not looking for them so i
no i think it could be
sort of both right she's looking for
these kids and i'm wondering if rather
than these kids existing in every
reality and she's just trying to find
the right fit
what if she goes rowdy by reality and
these kids aren't anywhere and she found
out that the one she created in her hex
might have been the only ones that
existed that's why i'm still clinging to
this i know at this point it's batshit
but
the mephisto train just because i think
at some point those kids being unique
those kids being specific to her one
reality
might clue us into where they really
came from they may still be
demon spawn it's just clearly mephisto
was not in this
uh but they're originally eventually
still pretty important and then they'll
do the ties
to one division for sure i have no doubt
that mephisto will come
eventually i do think again like how you
said we were thinking very preemptively
this is the first
of like a chain of so much coming
forward
that i we literally were like oh here's
what it is
look here's the entire basket and then
it was just like a couple things
yeah exactly exactly there uh and
ultimately
one division's greatest fan service
contribution was at least
setting the table setting the stage for
all these other crazy things to now make
sense
because we've been given a language
we've been primed to expect it
unfortunately this show's own writing
and own creative choices also primed us
to be kind of conspiratorial and nutty
like that's what i mean by expectation
management like
i think unfortunately uh evan peters
being cast as who we now know to be
ralph boner uh i think had maybe one of
them in the fourth title released
fans would have uh already gotten some
other kind of clue of how x-men are
coming into it but this being
i think they we'll talk about uh yeah
we'll get into it we'll get about we'll
get into boner and we'll get into x-men
but
but agatha's was giving us all kinds of
interesting dark-holed prophecies about
the scarlet witch
uh you're um prophesied to destroy the
earth and she kept saying like you don't
know what you've unleashed
jessica do you think it was something or
someone that
uh wanda released i think you really
wanted to be mephisto and i think that's
why you said someone
um oh i'm not saying at this point i'm
letting i'm letting go of it for this
part of the conversation i think it
could be uh
like someone like ghost writer you know
all kinds of demons and demonic figures
come from the dark
i mean or could be the demon that gave
her the powers to begin with
yeah that'd be crazy if he came through
the mountains and was like um
back on my life that's uh
i think it's her i think she just
doesn't understand the capabilities of
her powers
and i do think this is where okay so
people have been saying online i'm still
surprised that
wanda they people look at why or agatha
is the villain
and i was like she is the villain but i
think ultimately she's like
a chaotic good villain where she was
trying so hard
to take those powers away from her even
if she was doing bad she's like you
don't understand how to use it
i know how to use it i've been reading
and learning about you
my entire life and here you are with the
powers not using it in a well way
like even if she was gonna use it for
bad which
i guess whatever she was like i know how
to use your powers
you don't so i think she's like truly
like you're going
to literally kill everyone because she
actually almost did when everyone turned
on her
also no offense but the people of the
town should have been much more angrier
than sad
they shouldn't have been like kill me i
was like you guys should be jumping her
right now
deborah drew up saying that just let us
die was so
haunting like i was like girl but then
those are the scenes where i'm like this
is a villain like we we can feel we can
feel sad for her
but look at what she's doing to these
little innocent people
and then on top of that on top of that
when she
like was like stop and choked everyone
by accident
i was like literally agatha was like
i didn't do any of this you did this i
just literally cut the cords like you're
the ones
like you're the villain so i think she's
going to become
a major villain by like accident like
kind of
terrible analogy uh dark phoenix
like she's gonna be she's just gonna i
don't think she's gonna like knowingly
like she's just like all i want is my
children back but she's
harming everyone in sight yeah she's
kind of falling into that i'll call it a
trope
um misunderstood super-powered witch
uh character like we saw this in wicked
right both the gregory maguire book and
the the musical with edina
uh but like she's and it's all based on
the wizard of oz as this is they had
that great whistleblowers easter eggs
of the feet hanging out yeah oh so good
yeah where it's just like i'm trying to
make things better for you don't you
understand and people are like get out
of here witch
it's kind of that same thing that's
basically the look they gave her
it was such a weird scene and i was i
was more like affected by how sad they
were especially like
her being like i was every time i look
in the mirror i don't know who i am
anymore
i was like okay calm down you know what
happened
norm didn't even act that crazy like you
could calm down yeah no yeah yeah
but i think you're right she is kind of
this villainous figure and i think
that's kind of what we're looking ahead
at
the multiverse of madness she's trying
to find her kids we know mordo from the
end of the first doctor strange movie
said there are too many sorcerers he's
coming back in multiverse of madness
i think it's gonna be a chase a chase
through realities we got america chavez
coming in
uh she can like kick stars through
realities
she's an amazing character uh so she's
coming into this so that just tells us
it's gonna be a rapid
mad dash through the multiverse trying
to chase down
wanda and dr strange ultimately why he's
the best for this as we saw in that
nexus commercial
where it said ask your doctor he is a
doctor he is a surgeon he does no harm
he fixes
people and i think he's gonna try to
help her it's gonna be kind of like
in the way that vision versus white
vision was just a conversation
i'm looking forward to another
interesting conversation i
absolutely am um i just don't want it to
be so clear that like
her just i get her justification is like
my children i understand it can be
driven by like family completely
but if that makes all logic go out the
window with her and doctor strange like
doctor strange is like wanda
look at what you're doing and she's like
my kids yeah and like slaps him
i'm gonna be like okay i need some more
talking i'm gonna need some more
dialogue
than this i don't want her to be
hysterical or crazy yeah definitely not
don't and this is what you do don't you
dare make her like and i know that
there's like some people
like in the comics she is and she's like
this but i'm also like we don't also
need to follow exactly what's in there
we're getting our own version like
agatha was a villain in this and the
like comics she's helping her
which when she turned her into like
turned her back to agnes yeah
and she was like if i need help i'll
come back to you that's kind of cruel
where she even called her she's like
this is cruel is she gonna
like eventually go back to her and be
like how do i do this and turn her back
oh i hope so
a staple of the mcu she's been so
freaking great in this show
um and so i was so glad to see her not
destroyed by the end of this
and i and what i hope is that you know
she's not hysterical but
we started to see some sound logic from
wanda where she's going around to the
people the town she's like
i wanted to try to help you through your
grief and they're like no you're doing
it the wrong way
there's kind of some echoes of when loki
said to those germans is this not better
and it's a misguided view of like
someone who thinks and thanos has the
same world view right yeah
i'm trying to fix what the problems of
the world just give me a chance to carry
out my vision
and people hate what they try to do
slightly kill monger if he just wasn't
gonna bomb a bunch of people
right right the other part of his
justification yeah and then we just
mentioned what i
assumed in my view the three best
villains of the mcu thanos killmonger
and loki
uh all three were great because they had
an
almost understandable world view the
justice of the means to that end was
totally horrible
but like you understand where they're
coming from and then we kind of see this
with uh wanda now too
you understand that emotional place that
she's coming from you disagree with the
decision she makes to try to
to get there but like you relate you
relate and that's why it's a good
freaking show dang it dang it we have
more to talk about
before we continue we want to thank some
friends who helped us make it starting
with our friends at
magic spoon look we're all trying to eat
better healthy breakfast doesn't have to
be boring though
magic spoon has the amazing flavors that
you love without all the bad stuff it's
got zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs and
140 calories in each serving it's keto
friendly it's gluten free it's grain
free soy free low carb
and gmo free a variety pack comes in the
four flavors of cocoa fruity frosted and
peanut butter
go to magicspoon.com marvel and grab a
variety pack and try today
and be sure to use our promo code of
marvel at checkout to save five dollars
off your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
marvel and use the code marvel to save
five dollars off and thanks again magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
and jessica my favorite pivot to make in
any time
i have to thank our friends to our
friends
at blue chew we uh now have boners on
the brain thanks to wandavision
and bluechu has an answer
bluechu is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis
but in a chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost blue chewed tablets help men
gain extra confidence for when it's time
to perform
blue chew is an online prescription
service so you don't need to go to the
doctor's office
or have any kind of awkward
conversations or wait in a line with
pharmacy
it ships directly to your door in a
discreet package sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within
days bluetooth licensed medical
providers work with you to find the
right ingredient strength for your
prescription
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and they prepare and ship direct
so it's cheaper than a pharmacy so if
you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety info
and we have a special treat for our
listeners try bluetooth for free
when you use our promo code wandavision
at checkout you just pay that five
dollars in shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code
wandavision
to receive your first month free and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring this
episode and uh jess and i are
live on stereo as we record this stereo
is a live podcast app
that allows us to react to your
questions and comments in real time
we got a bonus q a with stereo listeners
gonna come up uh at the end of our
recording here it's gonna go up
on the youtube channel on sunday so your
questions in your voice submitted
through the stereo app
answered by us we're gonna be doing
almost daily podcasts throughout the
week coming up on stereo
in addition to all the same video output
we got coming out on the channel
it has allowed us to react to what's
happening even faster
and interact directly with you guys
answering your questions and fielding
your theories in real time
so be a part of the fun by downloading
the totally free stereo app and follow
us at stereo dot com
new rockstars or click that link in the
description again that's stereo dot com
slash new rockstar
jessica let's talk about that first
post-credits scene
one of the f was with monica and that
scroll
absolutely what do you think um side
note as you
did the blue chew ad i looked up can a
woman take and the first thing is
a viagra pill and oh they can
and sometimes it does work great just so
you know but
yes wanda the was the first post-credit
scene with monica and the scroll
tell me the timeline again the cinematic
universe okay
so uh one division takes place we
believe
either october or november of 2023 this
is shortly after everyone like three
weeks after everyone
returned from the blip and then we know
spider-man far from home takes place in
summer 2024 because
it's a summer field trip and it's a full
academic year
after peter parker returned alongside
ned and his friends
so it's about seven months before far
from home which also ends with a big
scroll reveal
uh and nick fury on that space station
alongside a bunch of scrolls
so squirrels are everywhere
yeah so this is the new this is the new
stones
this is the new stones this is the new
this is oh
i wouldn't say that but it is like it's
gonna be as important but it is gonna be
like
they're gonna be everywhere and you're
gonna be like can i trust this person
now that scrolls are in the picture
not saying squirrels are bad people if a
scroll is listening i'm so sorry but
you guys can make yourself look like
anybody
yeah so just to spell it out for you
guys when uh that random woman who had a
badge
uh pulled monica into the theater at the
end
and said uh you know i was sent by an
old friend of your mother's he heard you
were grounded he'd like to meet with you
uh monica's not at all freaked out she
doesn't ask who she asks where
so it's pretty clear they both know that
person to be nick fury
uh it seems like they wanted nick fury
to cameo here
but they already kind of brought in nick
fury at the end of spider-man
from home and had a squirrel switcheroo
there they do it so much they can do it
do you think that she's gonna be
i thought about this i was like do you
think she's gonna already like because i
know the avengers kind of aren't
i think but if they get back together do
you think she's gonna be a part of the
avengers or do you think she's just
gonna be working with sword
oh that's a good question i think that's
why
uh nick fury wants to meet with her is
we saw this new form of her power where
like
bullets go through her and they're just
gonna drop on the other side
new versions of these spectrum slash
photon powers
every week yeah and i think nick fury
why wasn't he interested to meet with
her before well yeah it's
interesting it's only three weeks after
the blip nick fury also blipped you know
so it seems like his whereabouts are
kind of unknown and again this is seven
months before
far from home so i'm wondering if the
way
just applying some logic here uh that
scroll group
must have been separate from sword or at
least a division of sword that yeah yeah
right i think there's something that
maria set up yeah i think they're oh oh
oh
that's true but it's like you think they
would intervene sooner
so i don't think they are they would
have definitely intervened sooner with
if maria
set it up and then monica's being like
literally a hostage
um they don't what i'm saying is like
they maybe they did
and it's kind of one of these things
where it's like well we haven't seen
them in the mcu so far so where have
they been maybe they have been behind
the scenes
kind of like jack bauer preventing
terrorist incidents you know every
season
24 hours a scroll was there if you look
closely there was a scroll
i mean look there's we think squirrels
might be some of the avengers i
you know pitch theories that like rhodey
could have been a scroll
or like howard stark could have been a
scroll uh he didn't revert to a scroll
when he died i guess
but uh sharon carter sharon carter i
think could be a scroll there's so much
about her we don't know maria uh
kobe smulders why am i blanking on her
name oh
um yeah i think she's definitely a
scroll uh so
yeah i think the idea is they've been
around and they've been helping
uh in little ways here and there they're
like angels uh if you
could just look maria hill thank you
off-screen brandon duh
i how many times have i said maria hill
my mind is going because i've crammed
too much mephisto in there obviously
that's true and you forgot maria hill
colby smolders i just forgot her last
name
that's because we already have we have
another marine there's a lot of maria's
in those
marvel cinematic universe are you
kidding me um now there's another one
well i think i think to answer your
question monica is going to join the
avengers
whatever the new avengers line up yeah
but is she going to be like carol
danvers though where she just shows up
to the big scene and then leaves again
because her powers are super extreme i
mean they're not like
wandas of course but they're still she
can eat bullets basically they go
through her she has like this
she's strong she's basically like a
little vision uh
she's just not a computer i want her to
be the leader of the avengers isn't
there an era where
where monica rambo heads up the avengers
lineup let's let her run the show first
they're lining it up for falcon
yeah that's the only reason why i was
like i don't know if they are but also
that we have
the opportunity the this we have the
opportunity
uh black people unite we are finally
taking over the avengers
but it like there's gonna be so many
pocs in the avengers and i'm so excited
good it's about time
so oh my god i'm so stoked everybody i'm
ready
now with all the new shows that are
coming to disney plus i was like oh
i'm so excited but i i don't know i kind
of i want her to be the captain i'd be
sick but i also want her to be looked at
as the
carol danvers where she's just like so
good so clean that she has to go
save other planets like she's like i'm
gonna go shoot through space like the
freaking hubble telescope like i don't
know why not the hubble telescope
or the apple uh whatever i don't know
the satellite that's in space
i got a float through space forever it
needs to take its photos it's awesome
looking photos
she does the peace sign and then
evaporates into the space
i i like that because that comes with so
much
power of just being like i show up when
i want
of like not even like where i want it's
like when you really need help i'm gonna
show up
that's why i kind of want her to be
working with the scrolls just be like
like for scroll invasion it would be
really sick that she's like a main
component
yeah you know i am excited to see more
stories take place off of earth
yeah i think even uh guardians of the
galaxy both of those movies for
as you know uh rule rule-breaking as
they were
both still had opening scenes that were
set on earth
and uh according to the galaxy cut back
to earth in that uh
third act i think only thor ragnarok
uh took place completely off earth
uh and that's part of the reason why i
love it so much so
i'm excited to see more stories that are
just completely set on other planets or
in other realities or between realities
like i i don't need to check in with new
york or whatever you know
truly i don't i'm not from queens i'm
not from
brooklyn um i'm from washington state
uh where no superheroes are from but uh
i'm so sad about that but um what was it
oh
i love horror that's why i loved juan
division because it was so scary and
then we're talking about
demonic stuff yeah and then next is
sci-fi and i
cannot wait to get more into cosmic
stuff i'm so
excited for us to get into gods you guys
the gods in space it's going to be
so much fun it's going to be so much fun
it's going to be one of those
new characters and we're going to learn
all about the celestials and eternals
it's going to be weird and great and i'm
so excited for eternals
i think i've talked about eternals
before on this show that i was like i
it's going to be
the door that just opened is going to be
phenomenal and we're not going to be on
earth anymore
now to give us a sense of timeline
because obviously this scroll post
credits scene
is setting up both captain marvel 2 and
secret invasion
and i looked ahead at the calendar so
captain marvel 2 was pushed to november
11
2022. secret innovation does not yet
have a release date
but it looks like it could be the next
disney plus series after she-hulk and
moon night which are going to come out
early 2022 we think
we might see secret invasion as early as
summer 2022 which would be
before and that maybe that's why they're
using all this time to set up the
scrolls and get people
scroll paranoid scroll paranoid
absolutely my friend
harry who loves this podcast he is so
excited for
moon knight to come in and i can't wait
for him to
have joy with moon knight coming in um
yeah
so i just thought about that as soon as
you're like moon night comes after this
so i
i think if we're looking not so much to
like what is uh
monica rambo's future as an avenger but
what is her role with the skrull
conflict if that if that is going to be
the next time we see your secret
invasion
i'm kind of wondering is there going to
be this civil war between people who are
loyal to the scrolls
and you know aren't afraid of the
scrolls and see them as allies
and then the haywards of the world uh
who view them as threats
that oh they've been maria hill uh this
whole time
the whole time i think that's gonna
happen but then they're gonna give
reason to do so like how in um i think
it was
civil war where they were like you guys
need to go under
like everyone's like everyone has to
approve of you to do things because
look at x things that wanda did i think
it's going to be like that where they're
going to be like
we can't trust you because of yeah
they're going to be like
just putting fear into humans that don't
have powers with situations like that is
what causes the fear
so i think it's gonna we're gonna have
three people we're gonna have the
haywards that like believe that they're
straight up completely evil or if
they're not evil that they can
do evil things um we're gonna have the
people that are on their side and then
we're going to have
the scrolls that are also just genuinely
bad because it's like
yeah i think we'll see like an an evil
group of schools
for sure they're kind of it's like what
uh ronan was
to the cree not all korea are bad well
captain marvel kind of made all the
creed look like
[ __ ] personally but uh but like
he's kind of a zealot and i think we're
gonna see the squirrel equivalent to
that
who uh makes they're like why are we
hiding ourselves
we're powerful we're bad asses let's
make people fear us
uh and they're gonna ruin it for the
peaceful uh peace corps
scrolls right peace corps uh and then
that's gonna be the conflict of like can
we trust the scrolls
and then we're gonna see this nice thing
of like who can you trust that was the
cool thing about the translation of the
comics who can you trust that's
absolutely gonna be the that's gonna be
literally the tagline underneath the
posters who can you trust
and then it turns into a war film again
so i think that's gonna be monica
rambo's uh
goal in that and try to get people to
say no we can trust these people we can
work with
people from other planets let's open our
borders to
other planets because they can help
defend us they can help
enrich our society she's gonna be open
about it and nick fury's gonna not
be but nick fury's on that space station
with him right now but i think he's mad
that they took their shoes
yes i also think it's like that they're
their own thing their own situation
like he's not with sword he's not with
this person he's not with this he's with
a third party
and they're still he's doing his own
agenda he's still like saving the world
being honest to himself and so i think
he's like it's kind of like how they
wanted wakanda to stay
under wakanda and no one to come um i
think it's gonna be a situation of that
where he's like we're better off if
we're off the grid
and then we just come in and people
don't even know that we're in
um so i do think that it's gonna be a
situation where
i know it's a little too close to black
panther for sure of a plotline of being
like
monica being like we have to let people
know that the scrolls are good and it's
like
but do we look but do we have to like
because watch them show the scrolls and
then immediately the
the the tyler hayward shows up and
attacks one
and then they fight back and then
they're like look see they are
monsters and it's like you enticed it
you idiot
i'm calling the entire plot line right
now
you got it we'll check back in on this i
think you might have it all
uh yeah plotted out um i want to ask you
jessica
um so you know uh where the
did white vision go he kind of like
poochied out
into the sky and where did he go where
is he headed out
i talked about it not too long ago and
this doesn't really answer the question
but this doesn't really answer the
question i'll say that first
but in the comics where when white
vision does appear he basically is like
okay deuces
we're gonna break up i'm gonna go do my
own thing she's gonna do her own thing
and eventually they meet back in again
and they resume their relationship
that's why i didn't cry so hard at this
ending because i was like i fully
believe they're going to do their own
thing
and later in the timeline they're going
to come together and she's going to be
like vision
and he's going to have his memories
because vision gave white vision his
memories
that why i said i don't think this
answers the question is i don't know
what he went to go do
fight thanos that's not there because
that's the memory he has since his man
ripping his diamond there's like no
white vision thanos instead he's like
you're lying where are you hiding show
me that body show me that body
just like this one i can come back like
we can't white vision he dusted
he's like i don't understand yeah and
then you have to do
okay so there's the ark there's noah's
ark
this is the only boat i thought about
metaphors he's like so the titanic sank
like my dreams of destroying thanos
yes and he just goes lucitania
and farts
and then i pay i give them 30 for the
disney premier access for that
yeah yeah i'm we're not sure yet either
but i think you're right jessica i think
he
uh clearly is they're they're gonna live
in the shoes of white vision for a bit
and he might be called spectral vision
there's you know that's kind of what
he's calling the comics
uh but he's just vision for now it's
just this dude that moment where um
yeah he did that thing that he almost
kind of did to ultron right he grabbed
his head and you see the gold take over
the blue
uh i feel like that that was a callback
to that and he's like
you have my thoughts now you're you're
with me i'm with you
and uh you're kind of awoken now and his
eyes went from that like dead blue yeah
like human eyes and he's just going to
paul bettany's
yeah paul bettany eyes i don't think
we'll see him right away
he's probably i don't know maybe he's
gone to oxford or something to study up
on the history
he's going to become a professor yeah he
could be the leader of the young
avengers he's kind of like hey
there's this protocol we want to help
build another new team
and whenever uh billy and tommy get
brought back into reality through
whatever happens in multiverse of
madness hopefully
or when miss marvel gets brought in i
know she's not part of the young
avengers but i think she might be part
of the mcu young avengers
uh and we have hawkeye kate bishop
cassie lang stature
i i could see vision be kind of a mentor
figure to them
and i i could see the multiverse soul
events doing kind of what they do in the
comics maybe one is able to bring in a
new red body for
this version of vision to to hey maybe
he just stays
white or he turns green again um like in
the comics okay so two things one
i just wanted to be clear that i was
right about paul bettany's cameo and it
being paul bettany
i was like it's paul bettany of course
he is and then as soon as the leak came
out that he was like
it was a joke it's just me i was like ah
yeah of course it is your little
butthole it was like of course
yeah i was like okay and then secondly
so does he only have does white vision
only have
wanda's memories so because wanda even
when vision and one vision was like
one question what am i and she was like
you're the piece of the mind stone
that's in me
you are me literally yours which one
beautiful monologue
i love that so much oh my god that is
when i cried
that that was when i cried because i was
like she loves him so much
and it is going to be left in this plot
of land by herself
what i love about this monologue is it's
a very weird
uh it's one of these things that like
it's beautiful
within the context but no one's gonna
use that for wedding vows
right i i hate it when people like just
quote uh these movies
uh or you said it's i yeah sometimes
like you you'll go to some weddings
and [ __ ] that would be insane you have
to no
what are you doing that's my rule that's
my rule
uh no uh pet names no kids names no
tattoos
that are references to ip
owned by these multinational media
corporations
because they will inevitably ruin that
character and drive it into the ground
i absolutely two tattoos and i have
three
no shame if you've done it
[Laughter]
three kids named paul bettany
elizabeth all these so many people name
their kids khaleesi or their pets
khaleesi and it's like that character
was ruined by hbo
like i don't i don't want to fall into
that i don't want to get a tattoo with
something that is owned by the walt
disney corporation
and they're going to do whatever the
hell with it that they want i've already
planned that i'm naming my child after
miles morales
so it's and miles morales can never be
bad
he's always going to be good but you do
bring up a good point i
think the the implication of uh what
memories white vision has now
darcy kind of caught him up and there's
that moment where we see the montage
of all the moments so it seems like
white mission is caught up no
but the reason he asked what am i is
because no one knows what the hell
vision is from age of ultron i that's
why i love that
is he's finally giving us an answer of
like what how should we see
vision in the mcu because he's made up
of all these different components
and then wanda just cuts through it all
and gives us this direct answer which i
i really really like i really liked it
that's true i forgot that she darcy did
catch him and darcy comes through last
minute and slams into tyler
i was truly like dar i was like cat
denning showed up for like
10 minutes and it was just to say have
fun in prison and then she never came
back
where did darcy go they were straight up
like monica was like
yeah she said something about debriefs
or for losers or for the week and then
left and i was like where'd she go she
just like
dipped out in her costume so what you're
bringing up here jess
and uh with the whole idea of uh you
know of white vision
and um i think we should talk about our
our last wtf for now
is ralph boner evan peters
are we serious here let's talk about
expectation management
um this is something that let's talk
about uh a lot of amazing tv writers
do fall into this trap is they tell a
really great story
their priorities are completely valid
and understandable and they they tell an
interesting character journey
but with these fan crazy
titles sometimes it can run away from
them
and while i think again that is largely
on the fans we're gonna fan
uh fans are gonna fan that's just how
it's gonna happen
but when you do things like you let paul
bettany promise a huge ass cameo
when you name your character boner after
characters have such
an excitement for him and you i i wish
honestly jessica they just cut that
scene like it could have been as simple
as
as pietro speeding around battling
monica cut to
her doing that dive tackle on him and
rolling him on his back and pinning him
that it could have been that simple we
didn't need to see that power bill
or that head shot where his name is
ralph boner that felt like
it's just gonna piss off fans you know
and they're not gonna
appreciate the joke we are writers
like we just wrote this like ages ago we
thought it was fun james gunn does this
stuff and
literally all of his films we just think
it's funny and then it was
us that was like okay ralph has to be
mephisto ralph has to do
this so the expectation management from
us also of just being like
it has to be this and they were probably
like oh [ __ ] we can't re-record the last
episode we can't just like take which
that's what i'm saying they didn't need
to re-record it they just could have cut
out the ralph boner thing
and then we wouldn't have never gotten
an answer on ralph you don't know how
hard it is
we would have gotten an answer on ralph
and then honestly people like us would
have chalked it up to oh maybe it's just
like that cheers joke of like the
off-screen like that we've never seen
now we have closure it was just a man
with the last name boner
and closure and disappointment for a lot
of folks i think it was
uh i think it was uh i don't want to
gripe too much about the show it was
great i loved
i loved it you know but there's just
these little things
i i don't have a problem with them
casting evan peters because clearly they
intended this to be the fourth marvel
title and i'm willing to bet that either
in black widow
falcon winter soldier or eternals uh
we're gonna get some hint to how mutants
are going to come into the mcu i'm
guessing it's going to be eternals i
think eternals is going to show us
the history of mutant kind of that's
just my theory that'd be cool yeah and
then that way i think
i think feige's intent was like here
we're going to give them the rules of
mutants
in this movie so that when they see evan
peters
after that they're not gonna be like oh
my god they're bringing in
all the fox characters i think they just
view it as kind of like a weird wtf and
then they would have just like laughed
it off but now that this is our first
marvel phase four title
that's what primed viewers expectations
so
you got to be careful about how you show
that there is a bit of responsibility on
the creator there
they'll probably learn from this mistake
but i do like which was like not even
necessary
at all that that was his head shot he
obviously is an actor maybe that's why
agnes chose him because he's probably
very good at
like acting though it's like you were
taking over his mind it doesn't really
matter if he's good at acting he
believes what you're putting in his
brain
but yeah i think they'll learn from that
and be like
and even like falcon and when i sold you
a little bit well we don't want to pull
a rock
we don't want to pull a boner like we're
not doing that yeah i i
cuz you know who loves to pull a boner
blue
i think we just got demonetized yeah
they're like take it out pull out
no i think and this is also like that
whole big mystery cameo really a perfect
storm right like
it was a joke by paul bettany setting up
a battle with himself
which like it was he's done enough
publicity tours
he should have known better at that
point this was after juanavision came
out and
broke the internet and people were
excited he like
and even matt shachman in a later
interview said look paul bettany
dug himself in this hole he can get
himself out he was clearly like kind of
annoyed that paul bettany did that
because it set up all these expectations
and the same week someone asked
elizabeth olsen hey do you have a luke
skywalker level cameo coming she goes
uh-huh
and then that was the headline but i'm
wondering she's like yes andy and like
what her co-star did
see i think she was referencing uh evan
peters
i think in that moment she didn't really
understand what paul bettany was saying
maybe that interview hadn't come out yet
and someone else asked her that around
the same time when she was doing her end
of the junket
and she was like oh we do have an
interesting cameo that is gonna like
melt people's brains
but you know she's not in the trenches
with the fans i don't think she
fully appreciates what luke skywalker
level internet breaking means
i think she knows i feel like her pr
team was probably like
hey if you don't know who luke skywalker
is it
no she knows who luke skywalker is i
don't think she fully appreciated what
that meant to fans
and what that what the equivalent of
that would be in one division
okay oh i think i think she i would hope
she would she's
the sister of the mary kate and ashley
all she knows how big celebrities are
i think a lot of celebrities say like
and look this is no nothing to shame
elizabeth olsen
these actors should like they have it in
their contracts that they have to do
interview after interview after
interview they're exhausted they're
she's trying to shoot doctor strange in
the multiverse of madison london right
now
and i think she's just trying to get
people excited and promote
wanda vision which is totally fine i i
don't think it's on her
i think it's on the creative team and
you mentioned uh james gunn
james gunn has an answer for everything
he is all over twitter he's taken some
breaks from twitter
but like over the years when you've
asked him any question about his
guardians of the galaxy movies
he has a well thought out answer he
spent a long time
writing out his treatment for those he
knew exactly what the rules of the world
were going to be
and they were so well defined jess that
that those rules
are what the russo brothers and kevin
feige used for the
uh infinity war in game movies things
that james gunn created as rules of the
mcu now
how thanos would work how inner space
travel would work
are things that james gunn created
because he's one of the nerdy minds
thinking that and that's what you need
behind the scenes of these things in
order to keep the fans at bay because we
are
rap at us we are ravenous ultimately i i
hope that fans can forgive some of these
like uh
fan expectation um missteps because
ultimately this is such a beautiful
story it's such a weird quirky
scary funny story and i hope the mcu
does more of this
you know i wonder even if you didn't
like this last episode you can't say the
last seven weren't ju like the writing
was so
good and you you felt her pain even
without being hexed
so it's like i'm not gonna denounce it
for
one episode right yeah let's segue now
into our final what the devil segment
let's talk about fisto let's talk about
it
uh i kind of gave you some clues that
possibly in that final scene
if you want to stay on the mephisto
train go for it because i think as jess
and i have said
he's coming in the mcu at some point and
one division definitely set the table
for it
and but in terms of him being in one
division yeah i
i blew that call he was not uh but i
think
i think many of you felt this way the
clues were there they were just pointing
in different directions they weren't all
pointed in the same direction
but uh i think that was a fair you know
uh reading
of those and i don't think it was too
crazy that a devil could showed up at
this cause we saw witchcraft show up in
this that's not
what i think that's what it was i think
we were eating
so much that we were like it's mephisto
but they were like they like showed us a
platter
with eggs and we were like can we also
eat the plate and they said they're like
no
it's right here it's eggs like it's like
it was agatha it was agatha here's
the demon devil stuff it's agatha and
then we're like but mephisto's
underneath right and it's like no
here you go it's agatha and we kept
being like but
devil and it's like but agatha and so i
think that was just
they were literally like it's in your
face and we were like it can't just be
that easy
it can't be that it's not just agatha it
can't just be
you have all these demons well and this
show as i said it primed us to be
conspiratorial
it's gonna sound like i'm blaming the
show for this but like
it's it's just like a happy accident
right where they say no the hexagons
actually do mean something and when that
was revealed all of us were like okay
every clue is gonna be important
and then it was later revealed not
everything was a clue for mephisto or
clue for whatever it's going to be
yeah and i'll say that like yeah
mephisto was one i was beating that drum
real hard but like
it like everyone was wrong whatever your
theory was for the show
it was probably wrong it was a nightmare
literally it wasn't grim reaper you guys
are dumb and i was like
it wasn't chiffon it wasn't dottie
it wasn't fox x-men quicksilver in this
uh
like the multiverse didn't happen
mutants weren't born yet
uh everyone was kind of wrong whatever
your theory was but that's okay
i think that you know uh a lot of you
are like oh you blue skull how do you
feel
are you gonna cry yourself to sleep
tonight no dudes this is have you
welcome to new rock stars i've been
doing this for years
and this is just like how i watch this
stuff
uh if you're grading me on accuracy uh
you're gonna be disappointed and i
assume you have been disappointed
before this uh every marvel movie every
video i've done
i'd like to reach a bit further for a
hot take that's gonna be wrong because i
to me that's more fun it's our mission
here is to gonna be
to change the conversation online about
this fan stuff
for too long the haters have dominated
the discussion
now the appreciators the stands are
taking back the throne
it's time for us to appreciate find
things to love about things
and to spend our time and our energy on
that rather than snark i'm done with
snarking oh
yeah no yeah baby because here at new
rockstars
we just tried to preach gratitude and
i feel grateful i feel grateful for you
jessica feel grateful for this show uh
and i feel grateful for marvel and just
being able to
talk about this stuff on youtube and
hear everyone else's theories i think
it's great
all the babies oh the babies
well as i said jessica and i are gonna
be back uh
in the coming days for one final a
wrap-up episode of
inside marvel wandavision um jessica
is gonna be a regular face on new rock
stars going forward
it's been such a delight having you
too bad i'm here all the time and i'm
going to
cry i don't know i'm just going to be
we're going to cry together
there's so much great stuff to come
we're going to talk about it all over
new rockstars has got
so many weird new formats that i can't
wait to share with you guys
uh so and not just jessica there's a
whole bunch of new people that you're
gonna love who are
joining the team oh i can't wait to see
stick around for that uh keep on the
lookout for that uh next episode of
inside marvel i think it's going to come
out wednesday
um but we are going to now continue the
show on stereo with an exclusive segment
of your questions and theories
and after party at after show download
and follow us on the free stereo app
stereo.com
new rockstars to be part of the fun
that's where new rockstars is doing
a bunch of weekly live podcasts that you
can interact with stereo dot com
new rockstars to join that conversation
uh jess
you have been amazing uh i love you so
much it's been so great to have you
every week
uh to hear your thoughts for you to call
me on my [ __ ] to hear your theories
because you're amazing [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what i mean
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's what i'm hoping
for
follow jessica at lulu underscore
clements but be
nice to her do not go talk some [ __ ] to
her
what do you guys do you guys lost your
mind coming at me my mom made a damn
twitter
she doesn't know how to use it so i mean
it defeats the purpose
but she sees some of your guys's
messages which are usually just like
honestly sexual harassment and my mom is
like
my mom will be like hey how do i message
them and i'm like
leave it alone oh i'm sorry you have to
deal with that jessica
but that's what i mean by we're changing
the conversation we're changing the
conversation
um so yeah i'm sorry
big and strong like drax imagine my face
on tracks
if you don't shut up if you don't shut
up about those
damn whoever jeff is i'm gonna find him
myself discord i wanna see those ever
again i never want to see those again
jeff and uh and janice julius on discord
both it's like this
uh face swap app it's disgusting so
follow me at ea boss follow the rockstar
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast so we're gonna close
with our favorite moment episode which
for me
chess it's gotta be ralph boner
boner
[Music]
you